I'll be back for sure Toronto is so much
fun and you know going to Toronto is why
you got one of the best walk-up songs in
that moment what are some things you
have to do when you get to Toronto
what's on the list oh
you get Draco Jersey I need I need Drake
to wear my jersey that's that's a
priority so if Drake wears your jersey
you'll say okay this was success yeah of
course all right I love it well I have
to say this feels very serendipitous the
jacket matches the Hat matches
everything so tell the Raptors fans just
how excited you are to be there and what
they can look forward to having Grady on
their team I can't explain in in any
words right now how I'm feeling
um I've been talking so much about
Toronto the city the people I always say
when I'm going to these workouts and
just learning about NBA teams in general
they either have like a good fan base
good people or a good city and Toronto
has both so it's a win-win situation you
know every single time and we're gonna
have some fun so I'm I'm getting ready
has anyone asked you to talk like uh
Donald dunk yet
doing that
yeah okay do you promise yes I promise
okay just know he has a great impression
we're gonna get it out of him but not
tonight all right congratulations we'll
see you in Toronto thank you